[Music]
do you remember like who your first
crush was well I I wasn't really into
boys I was a I was raised a very strict
Catholic yes yes yes and my mom wanted
me to be married to Jesus
that'll change when I the idea you're
gonna marry Jesus is she really wanted
not on tinder
well I named often Mother Teresa
yeah so she really wanted me to be a
good Catholic girl and when I saw Romeo
and Juliet it what it's what threw
everything out of the window and then I
became obsessed with Leonardo DiCaprio
and I used to wear these
I had this necklace I went to this very
religious Catholic school and and the
necklace just said Leonardo DiCaprio and
I would wear it and there were like
Leonardo DiCaprio makers there was like
a lot of stuff going on an hour late at
the time it was a big deal yeah but also
his name sounds like he could have been
an old Italian saint like I could see
true I could see the nuns not thinking
like kappa you're like oh he was the
15th pope you know
[Laughter]